Michelle Obama and Jill Biden are headed  to yep the first and at second lady will  appear on The Voice this coming Monday  May 2nd it's all part of the fifth  anniversary celebration of mrs. Obama  and dr. Biden's joining forces  initiative which calls on all Americans  to rally around to service members  veterans and their families offering  support through employment education and  wellness opportunities we know that the  country cares but we need to make the  connection between those feelings and  connect them to the families so that  they feel that support so it's not just  a conversation that it's a call to  action to say hey support a military  family and I think that's what with  joining forces is all about the audience  on Monday show will be filled with  active duty and retired service members  and military families